خيم تبادل الاتهامات بين روسيا واوكرانيا
بقصف اهداف مدنيه على ابرز التطورات
الميدانيه التي شهدتها ساحات المعارك
المستمره بين الجانبين اذ اعلنت الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في العاصمه ان هجوم
الروسيا بصواريخ كروز استهدف المدينه وان
دفاعات الجويه تمكنت من تدمير جميع
الصواريخ التي اطلقت من بحري قزوين في
مقاطعه التي تحل اليوم الذكرى التاسعه
لاندلاع القتال لاول مره فيها بين القوات
المواليه لروسيا والجيش الاوكراني اتهمت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه
باستهداف سد كارليفيكا القريب من مدينه
باربعه صواريخ من طراز اس 300 محضره من ان
ذلك قد يتسبب باغراق المناطق والبلدات
المجاوره في حين اتهم عمده المقاطعه
الموالي لروسيا اوكرانيا بقصف مركز البحوث
العلمي ما تسبب بمقتل شخص واصابه اثنين
فضلا عن وقوع اضرار كبيره في المكان
الاتهامات الاوكرانيه لموسكو بقصف اهداف
مدنيه امتدت الى مقاطعه دينيبرو جنوب
الشرقي البلاد اذ اعلن رئيس الاداره
العسكريه للمقاطعه مقتل شخصين واصابه 23
اخرين في قصف روسي اصاب منشاه طبيه وقد
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
قصف المنشاه بالعمل الارهابي في المقابل
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بيلغرود الروسيه تعرضا
منطقتين حدوديتين في المقاطعه لقصف
اوكراني الحق اضرارا بعدد من المباني
السكنيه وخطوط امداد الغاز والطاقه
الكهربائيه هناك دون وقوع اصابات بشريه
كما اعلن حاكم اقليم كرسنودار جنوبيه
روسيا تحطم مسيرتين في اجواء المدينه ما
تسبب اضرار الماديه باحد المباني بعيدا عن
الاهداف المدنيه قالت قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه انها كثفت قصفها على مواقع
القوات الروسيه على الضفه الشرقيه من نهر
دنيبر بمقاطعه خرسون وانها نجحت في تكبيد
القوات الروسيه خسائر في الارواح والعتاد
في حين بدا لافتا اعلان قائد مجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
انه تم تكليف قواته بالقتال على جبهه
جديده دون ان يقدم مزيدا من المعلومات عن
تلك الجبهه واكتفى قائد المجموعه التي
بدات منذ ايام تسليم مواقعها في باخموت
للقوات النظاميه الروسيه بالقول ان الوطن
يحتاج الينا للدفاع عنه